people on the left are like why you
still remember the labour party why you
still why would you vote for the labor
party the reason i would vote for it is
to destroy it
[Music]
i was a spokesperson for jeremy corbyn
between 2016 and 2017. i'm off
[Laughter]
one of the things i really like about
you is you
you know whatever your ideological
leanings you're someone who tries to
work across different lines and you
you're interested in talking to people
with different points of view and trying
to persuade people as opposed to you
know screaming shouting the way we do
politics nowadays right um and
how do you reflect on your time in
politics does it allow for that sort of
thing have we got worse at doing that
better at doing that what were your
experiences like
uh well um i've i've slowly come to
terms with the realization that uh maybe
we're not gonna build uh socialism in
britain
anytime soon
how did you realize that that's a
genuinely interesting question or wait
was that just a joke
no no i mean look obviously the corbin
project went the way the way it went and
uh had its
many different structural challenges
that
were he's gone into political speak now
it didn't work out it didn't work out
and look i mean i i think that there's a
lot of areas where
i
public policy and
governance can be improved and i'm
willing to and
quite enthusiastic about working across
party and working with whoever wants to
deliver those things and improve those
things and
quite pragmatic so if people share my
objectives and perspective on particular
policy areas which like i think gambling
cuts across political lines obviously
there are ideological elements to it of
course as we've touched on but i think
fundamentally like it does cut across
political lines and
and their scope to work collaboratively
and i think that there are other such
areas um and i think that's kind of
where i'd prefer to spend my energy
because
the labour party and the internal
politics can sap
a person's energy quite quickly and uh
create a level of despondency that
isn't productive yeah so yeah well i
wasn't getting it at it actually from a
sort of left right point of view i think
actually there's
there's increasingly this is also
happening on the right this sort of
tribalism and you believe this therefore
you must be outcast and we're gonna
cancel you from this tribe you don't
belong
uh like we had david starkey on the show
uh uh some time ago and he said that
he's pro-mandatory vaccination which to
me is an abhorrent view but david
starkey has a right to say and i'm still
going to be uh you know polite and have
that conversation even though i
massively disagree and then someone
wrote an article saying david starkey is
not one of us you know
and i'm just like
[Music]
you're not you're not going to get very
far in anything you're trying to solve
in the world if your attitude is this
person has a position i fundamentally
disagree with therefore
you you can't be spoken with and had a
conversation yeah did you see that the
is that a new thing in politics or is
that has it always been like this in
your in your experience
i think i think
um it's a relatively new phenomenon and
i think it's been brought about by
social media and the kind of silos that
people create and the echo chambers
and
the positive reinforcement that people
get from like-minded people and i think
that that that's
part of the issue yeah um i mean david
starkey may be
a slightly controversial example um
given some of his comments yes um but
like yeah i mean i think that it's it's
a relatively new phenomenon i think it's
part of the social media
era and
um
yeah i mean it's interesting i think
like because
like a
political strategy particularly for like
a left populist or even any any kind of
populist
movement would be to mobilize the base
and move the middle as a result
and
a lot of emphasis goes on mobilizing the
base and
keeping the base on side and happy and
as a result of that you know dictating
the terms of debate
so i think populism as well as a
political strategy has probably fed into
that i think a lot of parties and
successive political leaders have
adopted that approach
um which does i think polarize people
more
i'm
looking at the at the future of politics
and in particular the future of the
labour party
do you think that it's got any real
future in
a party as a whole because the reality
is look you would probably identify as a
left-wing progressive is that fair yeah
such a democrat yeah and then you look
at
kierstama
your values in kierstarmas are
completely opposite and i can't imagine
you being on board with what stammer
does
can the labour party really hold these
broad coalition of people together yeah
i think it's quite illustrative of
the um
how how polarized the labour party is
given
you've got a situation where
a new leader has kicked out the previous
leader i mean i know that there's a lot
there's a context and i know that
there's other you know facts that is
quite like a stalinist thing to do
exactly yeah it's like um
and you know it's i just noticed that
poster up there the audience can't see
it but we've we've got the poster which
actually is in our merch store which
says cancel culture is a myth and it's
joseph stalin's face on it yeah that is
the sort of thing that happens generally
in dictatorships right you come in you
get rid of the
previous guy yeah and um that's kind of
yeah so it does show i look i mean i
think one of the
things one of the best things that could
happen to the labour party is
proportional representation and the
labour party to split into its various
different factions and form
three two or three different parties
and then everyone goes their separate
ways and we can all live
in peaceful coexistence he really didn't
have a good
time for party
i agree with you and i disagree with you
i agree with you that actually it would
be far more harmonious people could get
their views properly represented
you know it would be it would be far
more effective as a party and people
would look at it the left-wing
progressive will go well i'm going to
vote for the momentum party you know the
center left people the centrists you
know the rem people who have
pro-remain etc etc would vote for this
party but doesn't that mean that
you're never going to get a left of
center or left-wing party ever be
elected ever well under pr the tories
would end up being split as well i think
is matt's point yeah that's right uh the
point and it's interesting that david
starkey's come up not entirely by design
but actually the point that he made when
we had him on and we were talking about
this he said one of the benefits of the
first passive
system is it prevents extremists from
getting a voice in the conversation and
he was talking then about the right
extremists but um
that
i am someone who's
seduced by the idea of proportional
representation but i'm also increasingly
aware that it's got trade-offs that may
not be what we want i can see why from
your position though breaking up the
labour party would be would be a good
thing yeah so the only way you're going
to bring that about is
is if there's a minority labor
government yeah so people say to me on
the left like people on the left are
like why you still remember the labour
party why still why would you vote for
labour party the reason i would vote for
it is to destroy it
i would i would vote for it so we have a
minority labor government that passes
proportional representation in a
confidence and supply deal with the s p
or whatever yeah and then uh and then we
all go our separate ways really so so
what you're you're saying is that you
don't see any future in the labour party
uh no i don't i don't
look i think it's a completely unstable
coalition between
democratic socialists like me
you know the social democrats even
and blairites now who control the party
who are
free-market
neo-liberals who
don't want to change the fundamentals of
the economy which uh
you know the fact that they can be in
the same political party it would only
ever happen under first pastor post both
parties are i think unstable
coalitions of many different factions
right i think they'd split as well yeah
do you think there's also i mean one of
the things we explored because look the
reason we started trigonometry is we
were to remain voting comedians quite
you know sort of center left or center
and then brexit happened and we were
trying to understand what happened and
why because
the one thing that i found very
unpleasant about that particular
conversation was i'm a dark-skinned
russian first generation immigrant and
the idea that half the country voted for
brexit because they hated dark-skinned
people or they were racist was that to
me is just a lie and it's a smear and
it's slanderous and to say that it's
just i to me that was just awful the way
that that conversation was being had
uh but one of the things we learned in
exploring and talking to a lot of people
who were former labor or members of
labor or blue labor or whatever who'd
voted leave
was the fact that the labour party no
longer represents the the very people it
was founded to represent right yeah at
least that's how they feel you might
disagree i don't know if you do but uh
do you think there's also a class issue
within the labour party there are some
people who are
you know university educated and very
progressive in their thinking and
they've read a lot of the right books
and whatever and there's also quite a
lot of people who just you know they
thought the labour party was about
representing them in employment
relations and regulating certain things
that the free market doesn't regulate
and making sure the state looks after
people and they are not on board with
identity politics they're not on board
with some of the more sort of new ways
of thinking let's say do you think
that's also a big split
i think the
the the culture split is interesting if
that if i mean i don't know enough about
whether that it does cut across
um
economic lines so i feel like our our
way of uh
conceptualizing class now is quite
outdated um i think you know we do we do
do it along the lines of education and
we do it along the lines of
like
what job people have and all that kind
of stuff but actually
i think if you look at
class on the basis of someone's income
there are a lot of consistencies across
like i'd say like there's there are a
lot of consistencies across like who
they vote for so people who are on lower
incomes overwhelmingly
vote labor still even in 2019
um
but if you had if you have like a
self-reporting way of conceptualizing
class like
asking for example retired homeowners
who have a few buy-to-lets in the red
wall whether they consider themselves
working class they'll probably say yes
because they had a working-class job
when they were working because they had
a job that didn't require a degree when
they were working
so there's lots of ways that i think we
conceptualize class that's quite
unhelpful in the kind of broader sense
but how
quote unquote the working class people
who identify still as working class even
though their material circumstances
perhaps tell a different story
might perceive some of these culture
the culture
issues um i think is very different to
how
how i would perhaps define the working
class the low-income workers who were
often very often also graduates you know
like people who went to university and
work in grad jobs in london in their
early 20s and are paying like 50 of
their income after tax in rent you know
these are also the working class i from
my perspective
so i i find yeah basically the way that
we conceptualize it is quite it's quite
interesting that is difficult for me
matt because like we on the comedy
circuit you meet people who went to
oxford who are very well educated who
both whose parents you know are wealthy
um and they make 10 grand a year on the
comedy circuit now by your definition
they'd be working class right
well
if they're from wealth and they don't
need to earn a lot of money no they do
need to they just don't because they're
comedians and idiots oh okay
[Laughter]
there are there are lots of different
factors i think that can
you know
contribute to you know how we how we
conceptualize it but i think the income
is like the primary one i think like
that is probably the thing that we
should be foregrounding
um whereas i think like what job you do
is sort of
whether whether you need a degree to do
your job or whether you don't it's kind
of i don't think that's as relevant as
how much money you earn yeah it's an
interesting point and the realignment is
happening for sure you're right
i got you with that idiot yeah you did
yeah because they are um but
the do you know are you not worried matt
where we are politically
because i would
place myself
in a different space you in in the
political spectrum but i look at labour
they're [ __ ] useless i look at tories
they're imploding they've got a fat
buffoon in childhood in charge
you look at competency on either side of
the political spectrum there's a dearth
of it
do you not worry and think to yourself
well
where is where is the left you know
where the new left side is where are the
new right side this and if you don't
have good ideas on the left and you
don't have good ideas on the right
they're not going to be able to
challenge each other and we're not going
to be able to move forward as a nation
yeah i think there is a real problem
with
a lack of vision and agenda
i don't think we've had a government
with an agenda
for quite a while in this country i mean
the the only thing that i can really
remember in the last
12 years
is get brexit done
and
it's done and like there's no kind of
there's no vision for the country where
the country needs to go we've got
leveling up now which is like a computer
game
no one knows what it means but we're
leveling up it's it's like there's a
there is a lack of ideas and i think
that we are in an
era now where there are so many
different challenges that need to be
confronted and there are different ways
of confronting them obviously but
you know the housing crisis climate
change lots of different things that are
happening that need big idea politics
and
everyone
lots of people criticize jeremy
obviously for their own reasons and
he at least did have a vision and big
ideas and when he said after we lost the
last election that we won the argument
what he meant by that
was
he was able to
define and dictate the terms of debate
everything was around
you know that agenda and lots of things
that
are now coming out of leveling up as a
concept
um
but because of you know jeremy corbyn
putting that on the agenda so for me
there's a role for the opposition
to try to influence the agenda of
government absolutely and starmer isn't
doing that he's just sort of hoping that
they collapse
i think that that's quite high risk
because no one knows what starman stands
for
if all of the problems can be pinned on
johnson which by by the looks of it the
tory party's gonna gonna do
then
the new leader is a clean skin and they
can just move on and they might well
have an
agenda um
so yeah i mean i think it's
disappointing that in this moment the
labour party could be making some quite
compelling arguments for how to reform
the energy sector you know lots of
different things that they're just not
they're just not on the playing field do
you not think that jeremy corbyn by the
way jeremy corbyn i agree with you
completely he was a person who had
vision of what he wanted now i
personally don't agree with what he
wanted on most things but he had vision
and there's no denying it but isn't
jeremy corbyn exactly the example of why
our politics is so broken now because he
had a vision when he was on the back
benches he came into the leadership
and the fundamental issue on which he he
was clearly euroskeptic if you're trying
to convince me he voted romaine i mean
come on right
but because of the way that party
politics works and the way that the
media works and the way that our brains
work where someone has said something we
don't like that means that person is
over we don't care what else they
believe but as long as they you know in
his case if he just came out and said
well look i've always been a you're a
skeptic i'm a man of principle i know
that my party doesn't share my vision
but this is what i believe but even
someone who i genuinely think jeremy
corbyn is a principled man i really
really do but he couldn't do that he
could not have the courage of his
convictions once he actually had some
measure of power influence within the
party
and i think that's why you see it on all
sides the moment you commit to a vision
people start attacking you and in our
world we just we can't handle it we
don't want to it's too toxic whatever
and i think that's why politics is
broken yeah i think when i was there
um 2016 2017 uh
we did feel
i think the whole
project felt much more insurgent and we
took more risks and because we felt like
we had nothing to lose
and then they changed yeah after 2017
you think okay we might get into
government and i think you start taking
less risks and i think that that was one
of the
things that really changed after 2017
was
you know
in that election
we did
accept the result the referendum and you
know it was very much on domestic issues
and then after that it was like okay we
need to sort of keep this coalition that
we've managed to build together
we don't upset anyone
and then when you get into that frame of
mind that's kind of it that's it you're
trying to
then he was just like any politician
yeah it became like he was exactly
that's how people saw him like so
yeah so that was and that wasn't his
game he he's not good at that no he's
not good at being it and you're right
it's the same like if we did this and we
didn't want to upset anyone
we couldn't do it it wouldn't be honest
conversations because an honest
discussion always will offend and upset
some people yeah and that's why we like
doing this matt do you think do you look
back at your time with corbin and think
you missed the real not you personally
but the labour party missed a real
opportunity if only they'd been a little
bit braver if only they had a little bit
more integrity if only they'd come out
and said look
brexit
we need to break it brexit means brexit
i mean theresa may theresa may stood in
2017 she didn't have a domestic agenda
she said give me a strong hand in the
negotiations i'll deliver brexit and she
couldn't do it so at that moment corbyn
should have said i'm the only leader
prime minister who could deliver brexit
so that that should have been the
message and then
failing that when she brought the deal
back which was
criticized by everyone and probably
needed labor's
um
it needed labor support to pass
it should have been
uh they should have abstained on it and
just let it pass you know
as and then
brexit becomes the tory's problem but
then what happened was the deal was
blocked it looked like labour was
blocking it because it was voting
against it therefore it looked like
labour's blocking brexit and then we had
two years of or whatever whatever it was
a year of wrangling over
a people's vote and the salience of
brexit was suddenly
the top of the agenda
and that's not an election that we want
to fight or we want to or we're going to
win and that's what happened so yeah
that there were successive areas i think
that that happened
um obviously it's easy in hindsight but
there were some of us at the time that
were saying you know we
we should be saying we're the only party
that can deliver brexit because it's
true we would have been able to do it
and matt
whenever i see the labour party and and
i see their
policies i just don't think they
understand ordinary working class people
i look at brexit they didn't get it
really they didn't get really why people
voted for it while people were
frustrated by it i look at their
attitude to lockdowns and i just think
you're crippling ordinary working people
they didn't seem to get it they wanted
more lockdowns
don't you think the fundamental problem
is that realistically you look at this
party and they just don't get what
working people who they are and what
they represent
i think for the first time
in
quite a long time i think well i i would
argue since 1997 in in 2017 we had
an offer to
the majority the vast majority of
working people people you know
that would have
credibly
uh improve their material circumstances
and there was a you know a blueprint of
how that was going to happen and it was
as i say people bought into it and it
was a popular agenda even though we
didn't win
so
that's where the labour party should be
in my from my perspective is like what
policies are going to improve the
material circumstances of people who
are living and most people are living
paycheck to paycheck yeah
and uh
that's where it should be yeah and i
mean i i agree i think on the civil
liberties stuff around
the pandemic uh things like vaccine
passports and supporting the government
in the restrictions that came in
[Music]
particularly towards the end
i think was a mistake it's not where the
labour party should have been yeah
i feel bad because you were here to talk
again by gambling and we did you can
just see we're really interested in what
you have to say on this so this it
wasn't like we sat down and we went you
know what we'll do 20 minutes on
gambling and we're hitting with the
corbin stuff like that wasn't the plan
it just it's really great to have the
conversation and as i said
you know earlier on i think it's
uh the the people that we always are
interested in are people who are not
tribal and who are not attached to a
particular tribe now you have your own
politics in your own vision but you're
interested in a conversation so we
really appreciate you coming on thank
you so much for that we're going to ask
you our final question and then we'll do
a couple of special questions for our
locals-only supporters great but thanks
thanks very much for coming on and the
last question is always what's the one
thing we're not talking about but we
really should be we're not talking about
fan ownership of football clubs
and getting the billionaires out of
uh well not out of the premier league
necessarily but you know at least
reducing their power football clubs are
community assets and i feel like the
they have that has been undermined by
the the marketization of football and um
yeah fans need to have more of a voice
finally a socialist policy great way
thank you man seize the means of
production
um you have nothing to lose but your
chains and your football club
mat thank you so much uh guys thank you
so much for watching and listening well
we're going to ask matt a couple of very
special questions from you for our
locals only but in the meantime we will
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go out at 7 pm uk time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
tony blair has a lot to answer for
[Music]
you